this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is brought to you by my
supporters on patreon who got this
episode of video game writing 101 early
and unedited being a supporter on
patreon also just helps support the
creation of these shows which I'm aware
are pretty Niche but I do think are
still very valuable to make anyway so if
you've ever been interested in any of
this kind of content or my voice acting
podcast or playwatch listen please
consider supporting on patreon and now
to the episode hello everyone I'm Alana
and welcome to another episode of video
game writing 101 today I am joined by
kariam and Mitch Carrie what do you do
I am a lead writer at Warner Brothers
games in Montreal currently the lead
writer on Gotham Knights Mitch how about
you uh I work for Carrie
pretty much that's for sure I'm an
advanced writer at Warner Brothers games
Montreal working on Gotham Knights
available October 21 pre-order today
great all right podcast is done episode
of uh We've nailed it yeah for anyone
who doesn't know Mitch also worked on
Star Wars Battlefront 2. that's an event
you've gone from Big external IP to Big
external IP yeah
yeah because I did Star Wars squadrons
too in 2017 and then moved to or sorry
sorry Battlefront 2 in 2017 and then
moved to squadrons and then some NDA
things and then now uh to Gotham Knight
so it's been a lot of uh franchises and
stuff kind of just by by incident it's
not necessarily intentional that when
you start working on a franchise that's
like a big well-known IP I mean I know
that you know Star Wars but do you just
have like months of research periods
well that and that kind of helped right
like on Star Wars I was already just
this like built-in huge [ __ ] dork so
I just had everything up here I was
already keeping up with all the external
media the comics the books everything
pardon me uh so and I was just
interested right like I was just a super
fan and always have been so I was just a
sponge for all new Star Wars stuff when
they started revving it up again
and that that probably more than my
writing was my asset when I got a job
working on Star Wars is like
sure I didn't have any experience
writing games but I know the [ __ ] out of
this material uh that's definitely
valuable yeah yeah and with DC it was
similar but different right like coming
in it's like I'm not uh an expert in DC
Comics I mean I'm a long time fan but I
don't know like every Arc I don't know
every book and the connections and the
Crossovers and even some of the
characters right like Tim Drake's robin
our Robin is probably the robin that I
know the least so it was cool to like
get to work on this project and get
exposed to the character that way and
have to learn like okay well like where
did he come from and what's his deal but
also separate from that like what's our
Tim how is he different
that's also not different enough that it
feels like a separate character it's
always a fun battle yeah if you don't
want to retread anything either that's
going to be an interesting challenge to
approach
like is I don't know how much you can
talk about it but
um to both of you is that a process of
like you all go off and you read a bunch
of comics and experience a bunch of
media and then your writer's rooms you
discussing different acts of different
things that you like and then you decide
what to pull and what not to
oh yeah for sure
um I wish we had more time to read
Comics it always seems to get eaten up
by like those deadlines and you have to
finish this thing or that thing but
certainly like we
um back when we were in the studio even
we used to have every month DC would
just send us a box of comics and we
would go through them and pick out the
ones that we liked and hell yeah they
trade paperbacks home and stuff and we
have access to a comixology account so
you read all of the things and you you
pick all of the things that you think
are best from various uh comic runs and
then you just go into a room and you say
okay what works best for our game and
the way that we're putting these
characters together and the way that
they're talking to one another like
where do we push their relationship that
we think it hasn't gone before but it
might or that will drive a plot in our
game in an interesting way
that makes sense I've actually never
asked anyone on this show before so you
two might be a good team to ask because
you do it together what what is a
writer's room actually like what is a
people hear the term writer's room all
the time what actually is a writer's
room this is my first one it's my lips
like
fourth-ish major production but my my
writer's room has always been mostly for
the most part has been me and a writing
partner
no way yeah Battlefront 2 was Walt
Williams and I and then we had some you
know external contract support uh with
like a editorial insights and narrative
insights things like that level design
or anything in on those
I mean yeah of course of course like
we're super collaborative with
everything but in terms of just the team
of writers the amount of narrative
focused people was always been very
limited for me in my experience until
now come to WB where there's a a genuine
writer's room and it's a delight I love
it man it's so cool being able to like
because I don't work well alone and
Carrie knows this because I complain
about it all the time it's a nightmare
for me to sit down and try to write a
book or a screenplay or something that's
the same dude it's me it's my project
publish it who cares I'll just write it
forever yeah and that's why you and I
text all the time about other stupid
[ __ ] we're not doing yep um but for me
it's like I thrive being able to just
sit down with Carrie and throw a bad
idea at her and have her go this is a
terrible idea let's pursue it with
interest
[Laughter]
some of our some of our best ideas I
think came from bad ideas or like jokes
that people made in the writer's room is
like oh if we wanted to do this like the
crazy way it would be like this or you
know you're joking around of like how it
wouldn't happen and then someone turns
around and it's like wait what why
wouldn't that happen because that's
excited whenever anyone in a writer's
room starts with okay bad pitch but yeah
I'm like let's go let's hear it what is
the bad picture on the grenade just let
it go yeah because people to come up
with a it's kind of um
uh no bad ideas is kind of the policies
like anything you think of you can share
and everyone can be like ah that doesn't
work and nobody takes offense and you
just run with whatever you can it's
better to share an idea than to like
hold it back because you're insecure
about it for sure but to return to the
question say it's my first day in your
writer's room what am I going to be
doing
so usually what happens is someone's
written a script that's gone through
um maybe even a couple of drafts with uh
the writer and the mission designer and
me looking at it and then we bring it
into the room we put that mission up on
the screen and we assign out rules and
we read the scenes
um now I should say this is how our
writer's room worked on GK like various
Studios have it implemented in various
different ways because there's no one
set way to do it but we read through the
mission and then we talk about it and
say okay what do we think of this scene
people offer suggestions
um writers talk about like what they
were going for if they achieved it and
then we just
fire ideas around
um and then you go and you write a
second draft and that comes back until
we feel like yes this is the best
possible version of this scene so
it's all things like our lines in the
correct character voice do we feel like
they'd say something else are we missing
important information what lines do we
we think are just absolute bangers that
have to stay
um because that's important too
otherwise you lose the the fun stuff as
you go along because people are like ah
nobody likes that line no one said
anything about it it turns out it's the
funniest line in the scene and then it's
gone and you're like wait I think we
have a joke in here or worse like no no
that's how we told the player where to
go please
don't take out the information you have
a lot of iconic characters how does the
team actually decide who writes water
you just are you writing different
characters are you all writing all of
them does someone have like a specialty
in a certain character like how have you
approached that kind of thing for Gotham
Knights
um Everybody writes a little bit of
everything but mostly I assigned out
um
like people had a character voice that
they specialized in and so it was kind
of understood if you were writing that
character that if anyone else had that
character in a scene the other person
had the right to come to you and say I
was thinking we could tweak this line a
little bit and people are no one was
super precious about it like everyone's
like no this works and we're not just
like nitpicking each other's lines
um and then after that we kind of did it
by by Mission because that's a chunk
that I can hand to someone I can be like
you go and you're working with this
Mission designer and you come up with
like how it's going to go in all the
dialogue and then other people come in
and have their say on like what the
other characters are doing or saying in
those scenes that makes sense um one of
the things that we were really lucky to
have actually is our cinematics director
Wilson wee uh is the best the best man
he is amazing
he came into the writer's room with us
which I have never seen a director do
and he would sit with us and he was the
one who was always
um pushing us not to have Talking Heads
which is something that you can get into
in video games because there's there's
so much information by the time you get
a cut scene that you got to kind of
stick it all in there and he would be
like you know but where is all of this
happening and we haven't used this part
of the set yet could we put something
there
um or like someone would have a crazy
idea about how like oh we could do it
like this but it'd be really hard to
film and Wilson would be like no that's
super cool
yeah let's do it um
and so he was he was there for that and
that's just into having more action in
our seats and I think it really shows
that's awesome yeah that's definitely an
easy thing to fall into I think I might
have said this on the show before but I
I added a lot of screenplays like people
just send me screenplays and I'll just
give an edit plus and I think the most
common mistake that I see is no action
at all it's sitting at a restaurant and
then sitting on a couch and then sitting
in bed like people rarely have
monologues that take place with people
physically doing something and it's so
satisfying I'm snitching those
screenplays
Mitch Dyer especially uh 100 guilty of
this it's easy to find that too and this
is why I love having someone like Wilson
on the team right and having a a group
of writers who are just very different
people for me who have different lived
experiences and different things that
excite them they can bring different
ideas to the table which is great
because for me like I'm a terrible
visual thinker like I just don't
I don't have like a strong Mind's Eye
for the way things should look and be
composed when I'm writing so I don't do
a lot of that which is great because
it's I mean it might not be great for
Wilson because it's a lot more work for
him but it ends up being play in his
hands right because he can start to
Define these things that I would just my
brain would never go to the places he
does and it just makes it seem better
because there are multiple people
involved functionally writing even
though they might not literally be
putting phrases and dialogue boxes yeah
for sure I mean that's that's a really
interesting thing about the kind of
teams that exist in game development I
mean even for the ride it's like I know
I'm really bad at writing romance I
can't write convincing Romance I'm just
not good at it like if anyone would ever
write romance I'd always be like this
can't be me you can take that I can do
all this other [ __ ] but that one it's
gonna sound like a group of teenagers
pretending that they know what love is
and I can't do it yeah but there are
things I can do that other people can't
do and you just have to figure out
everyone's strengths and weaknesses and
especially when it's a studio I don't
know how big is your team overall
hundreds of people
the whole team has several hundred
people we don't have several hundred
writers no that would be incredible
yeah no no I can't keep five of them in
line are you crazy
it's a writer's Coliseum
like raise the hand to speak
just out of curiosity do you guys have
like guides how do you make sure that
everyone is writing
these different characters in the same
way do you have like documents yeah
also Mitch you got blurry
I'll fix that it's fine this happens at
work all the time too um okay I'm gonna
just I'm gonna start answering this
question and carry if this beer isn't
the things I can't talk about please
interrupt me immediately so when I
joined WB I came aboard for a contract
in 2020 and to onboard onto the project
to learn everything about the characters
and the vision of the game and what what
this Gotham was I had really detailed
character briefs that were
just they were so good they were so
clear about okay this is not only who
this character is here's their major
life events but here's the things that
fundamentally like transformed them not
just uh you know like Jason Todd had
this bad thing happen to him and now
he's a tough mean man like it's informed
by more human elements and what was
really effective was having as well how
they view the people around them in the
Batman family and the and the enemies
and things like that all those character
trees yes
I love that then because I just the more
detail the more clear view you have of
how that character sees the world the
easier it is to understand who they are
and how to write them and what makes
them sound distinct when you have to
write a bunch of different variations of
lines for different characters
yeah and we have I mean we do that for
everything we have them for our gangs
have certain
um
lingo I guess that they
um when we sat down and we said okay how
do we make them distinct and what are
the things that they want and what ways
do they talk that are kind of unique to
them and we built out some basically
vocabulary that were like they talk like
this they use these words they don't use
those words those are the words that
this gang uses and you know how do they
refer to our vigilante Heroes and how do
they refer to each other and you know
what kind of slang terms are they
inventing for themselves without going
too far because
after a while it just it sounds like
you're trying to be really cool
yeah yeah exactly so yeah exactly
so so you've got these characters you've
got all the they all sound different
you've got I assume yes sometimes
character sheet character bio to make
sure that everyone has a different tone
I'm also already working with an IP to
put all this world together you've got a
lot of foundation there how much of
yourself goes into writing on a property
like this like are you still pulling
from personal experiences a lot or do
you feel like it's mostly already laid
out in a lot of the reference material
I think you always find something that
you can relate to in a character
and then you kind of draw on that like I
can't say that I relate to Jason Todd
because you know I've been dead and
brought back to life but like he he has
a lot of trauma and grief that's made
him kind of an angry person that he has
to work through and I think
a lot of people understand that kind of
frustration and anger and so you can
really draw on on that or you know
[Music]
um
and it's it's the same the same for
Barbara too but like all of the
characters have something that you're
like I relate to that in this character
this is the part of them that I get and
then you can draw in your experiences to
write that
um and then if there's something about
them that you don't get you hand that
off to another writer or bring in
someone and be like I was thinking this
and they can be like no that's terrible
about how anyone would do that would you
agree with that [ __ ]
yeah I think uh I I for me I definitely
put enough of myself in the characters
on a first draft that they all just kind
of sound like me they might be saying
things they believe but they certainly
sound literally like I wrote the lines
which yeah great so then it requires the
past like okay I need to go through this
entire thing with okay how would Eiden
versio say this how would Del Miko see
this and how would his response change
based on that depending who the
characters are
um
oh I had a second part of this today
well I can be a lot slower about that
because I make sure that every line
sounds like the character which means
that I'm doing that line by line the way
you're doing it is probably a little bit
faster which is just like get the scene
down in the words that need to happen
and then adjust the phrases for each
character yeah
I'm I'm a huge fan of because I I can
nitpick later and I will nitpick later
but early on I'm a huge fan of just
getting
like just popsicle stick glued together
that vaguely looks like it has a shape
and like okay we can work with this and
go go deeper or or however we want to
approach it but just having a skeleton
or scaffolding of something
counts for so much because for me that's
my first hurdle my the worst thing for
me is having a blank page and not
knowing what direction to go like if I
know okay this scene is about this
specific character having this
experience and then they learn this
thing and then they need to go that way
great we can find ways to imbue
character conflict and human elements
within that no problem if you're telling
me like okay great like come up with the
first thing for the first time I'm like
useless right so I just have to have
something to start with yeah like
kindling the way that I thought things
that aren't work related is um and I've
said this before is I write it like it's
a kids book and then this happened and
they went here and it's all very basic
like no adjectives just because then I
have it on the page and it's easier to
expand because I love asking people what
like writing books they recommend but I
slanted um Stephen King's on writing a
bunch of times because his approach is
just right like easy for you to say dude
like
he's not wrong I'll do that come on and
it's uh Tim Schaefer was telling me
about something he tries to frequently
do called free writing which I actually
hadn't heard of before I'm like wow they
really should have taught me that in
University
um which is you just set yourself 30
minutes you have to keep writing and you
can't stop and you just have to keep
writing I was like wow that's a really
good exercise for people who probably
stop and edit their own work a lot and
something that I'd never tried before
and I have tried it since he mentioned
it and it's like such a nice way to also
realize your own patterns of repeating
phrases you know but she say sometimes
things just sound like you I've got
plenty of those I use apparently too
much yeah we all have those little isms
where it's like okay that's definitely
Mitch's page yeah 100 said this stupid
thing again yeah
every time I read anything you write I'm
like oh stupid idiot look what he said
now oh exactly
um do you have any any advice either of
you like of of things like that that you
think that writers can do to to stay
fresh or to get things done even I
always start with a zero draft
um which is very similar to you writing
out like just the phrases of what has to
happen and when I'm doing a scene or a
dialogue I often just rough things in
with the stupidest dialogue imaginable
so it would be like haha and then I say
something funny here and it's like haha
I laugh at your joke and it's like yes I
made that joke because now we're friends
because I know that I need a scene where
these two characters move from we kind
of don't trust one another to be sort of
do and so all of that dialogue is just
me getting the rough shape of the scene
it's like a
um also a good idea job goes here it's
very funny they bond
exactly and then as you go through you
can start moving in like what you think
that would be where are they standing
what exactly are they talking about oh
here is where I have to give you the bit
of information that you know your father
is dead or like you know all of those
things so
if you start if you have troubles
starting at all starting by roughing
things in and just getting the rough
shape of the sheen the scene like a
painter roughing in the background I
think
um is a good way to start doing it Mitch
how about you
uh I've recently become and this is
really just because of writing games I
used to be big on uh there's okay so the
thing that people talk about when
nanowrimo comes around is there's
planners and Panthers right Planters are
the the rigorous outlining people they
know every detail of the thing before
they begin uh and then there's panzers
which is me which is I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing but I'm sure I'm just
gonna start I'm just gonna write and I'm
gonna improvise the whole thing all the
way through which for me was a recipe
for disaster
games because they're so just viciously
planned out right every step of the way
you've got your Sprints your Milestones
you've got all these very specific
deadlines
you have to plan and learning to plan
has been like the most satisfying thing
for me as a writer since doing this is
like
yeah it's awesome to like have action
figures for Star Wars characters I made
or whatever and that's like we love that
huge fan of that but like from a like a
craft perspective or whatever
from the the process perspective I'm a
huge fan of uh the most simple way you
can outline and not giving you the the
shape of the story like
uh like you were talking about with the
the just like writing it like a kid's
book and then and then keeping it simple
I'm really bad at simple I'm really bad
at simple I always over indulge I'm
always way too self-indulgent even in
the outline so I need to start shaving
it back okay a sticky note if it can't
fit on the sticky note your [ __ ] is not
well thought out enough and it probably
needs to be two beats and then starting
to put those sticky notes on a wall or a
mirror board or a Vizio chart or
whatever it's going to be right visual
stuff
the original uh pitch for God of War was
like on the back of the napkin
in handwriting
like that's what it fit on and here we
are
yeah I was trying to write this fantasy
series when I was a kid and I still have
a lot of it actually
um it'd be so interesting to go back
through but I ended up getting very
caught up in well what do they eat in
this season yeah like what kind of birds
are there at this time of year and then
I just was like I need to know all of
this information I at one point looked
up bomb making and then had a breakdown
because I was 13 and I was like am I
gonna get arrested because I Googled
such how to make a bomb for this fantasy
book like a lot of stuff that was like I
figure it out later it's fine see for me
that stuff is always like the excuse to
stop writing it's true it's also fun to
learn yes and then you come out the
other side and like I know so much cool
[ __ ] I'm absolutely breaking every
single hello FBI yeah
you do what you can no it's definitely
an interesting struggle and I think you
also pair with video games which is a
very unique thing about writing video
games is
literally having to write things to make
sure a player has informational
Direction which I imagine is something
that you've had to deal with with Gotham
Knights being open worldy I don't know
how open world exactly it is but you
know how how often do you have to have
meetings with other departments to be
like okay like you know maybe we play
tested this and there's not enough
Direction in this area and we need to
add a line of dialogue to make sure that
players understand because it's not just
writing characters from the heart it's
also writing to serve a person who's
interacting with it right
and and so many times uh and uh Lemay
who's our narrative director and I have
been in those meetings and when you're
making a game and like there's you know
UI bits that aren't in yet and there's
bits of the level that don't look
they're they're gray boxes they don't
look like what they're supposed to look
like yet and so someone's like I sure
wish there was a line here that said I
should go up the staircase no
please no there is no staircase yet it
will be there yeah or like you can't see
the staircase because literally like
you're just flying up there because the
designer hasn't built this staircase yet
or whatever like it's probably a bad
example but you get the idea
if we put in too many lines that say I
should be doing this thing right now
then you have a problem with the level
and that's not the writing yeah so I
guess you can also like kind of cheapen
your characters by using them to deliver
too much contextual information rather
than character-based information will
make them annoying and or they just
sound fraudulent yeah yeah and you
really have to be careful I I think we
kind of have a standing rule that we
should we should not have an I should
line of dialogue oh yeah uh anywhere in
the game because if you're just saying I
should do this thing you can always make
it more characterful yeah I think I
should do this thing is really just like
a chore for the player you're just
giving him a chore really and nobody has
ever said I should do this thing without
right before it yeah that's true it's
true nobody ever goes I should walk up
that staircase
never God don't talk to me about my
[ __ ] laundry I don't want to talk
about it
but you for example in GK we're writing
characters who are detectives so there's
an angle right there where you're like
it looks like there's something up there
wonder what it is and that will give the
player a hey go up and get the
collectible
uh because we want you to rather than I
should go up there and see if there's a
collectible on that ledge which is bad
and it keeps you in the world so there's
a trick to that too
question off of that
um across any of the games or any of the
studios that you've worked for what do
you think is the most difficult part
about writing video games
the most challenging part of your job
I think turning an idea because ideas
being the dime a dozen that they are uh
and then a big part of my learning
process in this uh career was learning
that like I had a great idea but that
doesn't mean anything like that was my
idea it doesn't matter like 10 million
other people made it even better yep uh
but turning an idea right I have a cool
what if we tried this interesting thing
or I've always wanted to see this and
turning that into something that not
only like functions within the framework
of the vision of the project you're on
because that great idea that you've had
for 20 years might not actually be
appropriate or interesting for the game
you're making but doing it in a way that
is is coherent in the in the context of
the story you're telling and
entertaining on the sticks without being
distracting right if you can and I wish
I had a better specific example for this
right now I'm just kind of rambling but
if anything you can do to make players
receive story without them realizing
it's even really happening yeah but
without them like it going through them
like if you can through the actions of
the game and the world's reaction to
their actions
give an authentic or distinct bit of
color and texture to a player's story
that's going to be
meaningful in a way that just like a
beautiful cutscene isn't you talking
about like finding personal ways to
deliver exposition
yeah and again I wish I had a great
example for this because I'm just
talking [ __ ] right now but yeah it's
like just being able to deliver a
character moment or a an a lore thing or
like a a joke even in a way that doesn't
distract from the gameplay that doesn't
say stop walk listen to our funny joke
all right now proceed back out into the
video game yeah that kind of thing you
know
yeah
and sometimes the hardest thing can be
like how something looks in context
because it can look very different in
your head from what it ends up being in
the game once you have it happening at
the same time as the gameplay
and that's
why you have to play your missions as
much as possible as soon as you get
those lines of dialogue in the game even
if like for us sometimes they're robot
voice
um
because it's the funniest thing in the
world that's good too you have some of
that it's yeah I love it so much
yeah just like someone on the sound team
is just like doing the best acting their
heart out it's great
that's all they're a lot of fun to
record too yeah that's true you mostly
do robo voices
yeah
and there's there's so much that I think
pulling the dev team off the floor to do
this yeah would just be
um onerous but we we have for small
demos done it on occasion
um I when we did the Naruto games back
when I was at Ubisoft one of my first
projects they made me Naruto no that's
awesome I wanted to be one of the cool
characters like Tsunade and they were
like no you have the voice for narrative
Naruto did you go believe it every time
you could uh I did not because we had
cut it from the game by that point oh
that's a very early on in the anime and
then not later so uh our licensor was
like yeah you can take that out if you
want so we did mostly but yeah I did get
to do some of the combat marks on the
team all thought it was very hilarious
that's awesome
you so you worked on Naruto did you say
you also worked on Assassin's Creed yeah
Assassin's Creed Prince of Persia oh
cool Harry has such a braggable resume
it's insane really I would like to hear
it let's go brag
uh let's see I worked on the Naruto the
broken Pawn that was one of my favorite
uh my favorite my earliest games uh my
favorite was probably Assassin's Creed
Syndicate I wrote Evie
um
that would be favorite before GK I
should probably specifically of course
uh because then I got you right back
uh along with several other like really
fantastic writers uh and I worked on
Prince of Persia Forgotten Sands
um and then because you're at Ubisoft
and because you'll be between projects
um now and again I got to work on kind
of a little bit of everything so I've
worked on uh
one of the driver games I think I worked
on
um
one of the Just Dance games I wrote
lines of dialogue not lines of dialogue
but more menu stuff for them yeah I
guess they do have dialogue though like
someone's gonna write the the dance
instructor you're doing great yeah the
encouragement yeah absolutely thought of
that
huh yeah so and so sometimes the
projects are quite small or they're
little like side projects for people and
you end up popping into help or editing
menu stuff but Assassin's Creed I worked
on my first one was AC3
and I did Assassin's Creed Unity
Assassin's Creed syndicate
and Assassin's Creed Odyssey was the
last before I left to join uh the
government I gave that a 9 out of ten at
ign.com so my last reviews there
actually I love that game really no I'm
wrong actually I'm thinking of Origins
his Origins I was already gone by all
the CEOs sorry oh no at least they're
both so good though they are both great
um yeah so expanding all of that you
know I'm gonna just like extrapolate the
question I already asked like what would
be the most difficult thing about
writing on any of those projects like
something that stands out to you is like
an early challenge that you just have to
learn from
I mean learning where the gameplay and
the dialogue work together is probably
the hardest trick and even still
sometimes like I'll write something or
someone will hand me something and I'll
be like this is great let's see it in
the game and then it's in the game and
you're like oh that doesn't work
um
so but there's hard Parts at every point
in the project sometimes when you're in
the planning sessions but those
um
those scenes have got to get written
it's just finding the time to sit down
and write yeah and then other times it's
the barks thousands and thousands and
thousands of barks like I'm gonna hit
you I hit you really hard oh no you hit
me really hard oh no I'm going to run
away like 20 times over for three
different characters and you're just
like oh my God please let me die
and we dig these holes ourselves because
what always happens is we say you know
what you know what'll make these barks
better than the rest of the barks a
shitload of variations yeah we're gonna
have so many variations for every
possible scenario you can think of if
this happens we have a response if this
happens you have a response and then
great can you write those and you go oh
[ __ ] yeah that's right that's right we
have to do that do you also have um and
for a game like Gotham Knights because
I'm just so curious about how it works
systematically like a banter tool that
you have to work closely with or maybe
like narrative design to make sure that
lines trigger at the right place in a
kind of open world where people can
approach from any angle like how do you
actually structure
when the lines of dialogue are triggered
we have people for that they are voice
designers and they are very good at
their choice designers I've not heard
that before yes uh we have on our team
at present we have three voice designers
um and they are responsible for like how
should the lines play what does the
system look like for the banter and how
people talk to one another
um they get us to write them and then
they offer us feedback based on well no
this is not how the system won't work so
this is how the system works
um they say oh we don't have a line that
does blah we need to have that written
and we get them to write the
descriptions for us they're quite
specific about like this line plays when
someone sees you and you are playing in
Co-op and they are surprised because
you're not supposed to be there it's a
secure location or like any number of
different things and then they give a
task yeah yeah and as I was saying it
becomes quite a lot of lines yeah very
very quickly I mean I imagine this is a
question that you can't answer but I'd
love to know how many lines of diet look
there are in Gotham Knights because I
feel like with all those characters and
that you don't have you can sometimes
play as some of them but you don't
always have to play as all of them I
don't even know how to approach what
you've done on this game I'd be like
tell me how all this works functionally
I don't understand because it's it's it
seems just seems like a lot of
opportunity for things to be missed or I
don't know
the Assassin's Creed games we generally
kept to like 70 or 80 000 lines I don't
know exactly how many we have in GK I I
think it's probably comparable yeah it
makes sense yeah a lot of recording oh
yeah it's a lot of recording yeah
spanning a long time I imagine you've
got a few years months and months yeah
no when we started when we finished
probably more than a year yeah yeah
that's nuts you work closely with the
actors to make sure like you understand
that voice so like does that inform any
writing decisions again on any of the
projects you've worked on you like
you know watch a TV show that an act is
in and then refine your script and be
like oh well this is how they might
approach that how they might say that is
that like a part of your writing process
Mitch do you want to take that one I was
gonna wait for you okay
um I I love being upset with our actors
I usually wait until we're on set to see
um how they're going to approach the
character but definitely like every time
you're on set with an actor and they're
portraying the characters like
they bring something to the line so they
bring something to the scenes and you
get that they understand that character
and I'm like we're forever going back to
the studio and being like okay now that
this person's read for it like you don't
need that line I don't need that line of
action text I don't need that line of
dialogue and we can really pare it down
and pair it to them like or definitely
scenes in probably everything I've
written where I'm like absolutely I know
this this line in this scene is for this
actor because I saw the dude or I know
they can do it
um and everything gets so much better
once once you get on this out with them
it just gets so much easier because then
you have their voice in your head that
must have been a very cool thing to
watch with Gotham Knights is like
writing these characters and then just
seeing these again they're all very
different I assume uh I'm watching them
come together when an actor like says
the words and you're like wow you're
really good at this
it is stacked and they all are
unbelievable yes I I was talking to uh
Elias to fixes who plays Penguin a
little bit about his work on the game
and it sounded just super exciting and
he was like I got to do some stuff I
never done before I wasn't sure I was
right for it but we nailed it it's like
it sounded really fun
that's my favorite part of the whole
process working with actors like Far and
Away my favorite thing because one it's
the first time anybody ever gets to see
what the story is really gonna be yeah
like on the page you've got okay like
not not only have we gone through
iterative process and and chiseled this
thing into perfect marble
now it's ready to shoot this like
Harry's saying the second you get it in
the actor's hands and you see how
they're going to bring the character to
life and how they're going to represent
things and they'll make choices that you
did not expect they will read lines in
completely different tones or uh with
different intonation than you expected
in ways that blow your mind because it's
10 million times better
um that fundamentally reshapes how I
think about our scripts like knowing the
actors and what they're bringing to it
because it's it's a collaboration right
it doesn't just the script doesn't get
done and now we're done and it goes to
the actors and then great they're done
and now no it's like there's a lot of
push and pull there's a lot of sharing I
remember on Battlefront 2 when we were
filming our uh performance capture cut
scenes
we went down and we did a table read and
it was very evident that we were going
to need to do a lot of rewriting around
these these actors because they were
fantastic uh and then when we started
shooting it was so collaborative that
like I would get you know I don't have
to talk to the actors about okay well
this is kind of the emotion of the
of the scene or whatever of your
character in the background it might be
subtextual it's not something that
you're going to say out loud but it's
it's there and that's kind of background
context for your character other times
uh like Janina gavonkar who played Iden
versio she and I sat down and would just
like
do uh you know we'd read pages together
but in the process of it we just start
rewriting because it was such a
collaborative experience uh and because
it was so evident that we needed to
change some of the words like the school
we were proud of the script everyone was
excited by the script but the
personalities that they expressed uh on
stage I don't know it just to me it
necessitates a rewrite almost yeah and
it's a cool
didn't you kind of have Janina in mind
before she was actually cost
no so okay Janina
I can't remember I think she's told this
story somewhere uh Janina we had we've
done a ton of auditions for Aiden and we
saw a lot of fantastic actresses who we
thought were great but nobody nobody
like lit us on fire I'm like that's it
it's her which is what you it's the
moment you wait for when you're doing
casting right and if you're not getting
it it's very concerning
so Janina was somebody who had worked
with uh some of the team on Far Cry 4 uh
some of the folks who would come over uh
from Far Cry were working on Battlefront
2 and they said hey let's reach out to
Janina and she sent in an audition sorry
that like just everybody in Canada in
the whole games industry is at some
point worked at Ubisoft like it's just
yes they came from Far Cry yeah that
makes sense yeah everyone but you Mitch
it's nuts yeah maybe someday it's
inevitable maybe someday we'll see I
don't know
uh but she so she sent in her auditions
and the thing about that audition was we
had written at two different ages right
because in the the Final Act of the game
which we uh the extended uh DLC content
takes place 20 something years later
during The Last Jedi timeline so we we
wrote two scripts of in different ages
and she just nailed it like she just
brought
what you're looking for you know yeah
and in our minds like we saw her tapes
and we're like yeah that's it that's
Iden versio but Janina had also sent us
like an endearing email about like hey I
just want to thank you guys for the
opportunity this is such an exciting
project even if I don't get to be a part
of it I'm just really excited to see a
woman in this role and and I'm I'm
really excited to have had the chance to
try to represent her in a way that
whatever right she was just so genuinely
enthusiastically excited about the
project the team and everything we were
doing and she you know it was like that
last little appeal of like hey don't
forget me I was I was a great audition
right and we were like you've already
got the role
this very nice email you were a lock but
this was very nice yeah that's awesome
um but uh Circle back to the question
which I'm now forgetting what it was
that Mitch jumped off of
Carrie Ann said what the [ __ ] was the
last question I asked nobody was talking
about something difficult about the job
and then we talked about other [ __ ] yeah
well let's jump into your favorite
things then I guess that's a mitch you
started off very well there if you said
yeah I guess that's kind of it yeah
Carrie what would you say is your
absolute favorite thing about riding
video games yeah seeing those scenes
come together yeah
yeah
they're great moments too when
um a lot of times it happens when you're
writing cutscenes because that's when
you get to write like a whole thing
together and you're like oh yeah I can
feel it I can feel how this is going to
come together but like just seeing a
mission come together from start to end
and be like hey like that that works the
scenes work the characters work the
gameplay works it all comes together and
you just oh my God that joke is funny I
am funny
validated somebody laughed somebody
laughed about you
um so then to completely depart from
your work on games and ask a more
industry broad perspective to the two of
you for my last couple of questions
what do you think uh is something that
you would like to see the industry as a
whole improve on where video game
storytelling is concerned I think there
are a lot of things wrong with games
writing and places we gotta go
where would you like to see the the
industry change or evolve in the near
future
I think I'd like to see and again I wish
I had specific examples although maybe
it's probably better that they don't
have a specific example say like this do
better than this very specific example
that would be hard yeah exactly uh I
would love to see more trust in players
uh allowing players to engage with the
world and the story in ways that they
find interesting not necessarily holding
their hand every step of the way
um I think something like I'm all about
a linear structured experience sorry I
would say something like Alden ring has
proven that you can do that and still
make a lot of money yeah but I think
that's a specific example too right like
the the from games get that reference a
lot with like inferred storytelling
through like lore descriptions and
that's fine and that's valid but I think
for me it's like
I love The Last of Us deeply the game is
very structured it really does it trusts
you to to scaven and survive but a lot
of the time it's very
it expects you to do specific things
right there is a definitive solution to
this problem and that's fine uh but I'm
I'm most excited about
sandboxes I guess and just I'm a huge
immersive Sim dork is basically where
this is going
um and just allowing players to engage
with the richness of narrative and
design that uh rewards them for that for
that investment right you don't
necessarily need to read every single
note in Dishonored but if you do you'll
find not only character information but
like secret codes for lockers and and
Alternate Routes or things that you just
never would have found unless you were
making other player choices like using
your powers to go up instead of forward
or wherever you're supposed to go or
disobeying an order and doing something
different than the game necessarily
expects you to
um you just started talking about
Dishonored and I like got chills it's
like it's just every time I think about
Dishonored something happens it's Disney
it makes my my mechanical psychic heart
grow three sizes that chin Dosh riddle
still thinking about it paper out dude
so let's [ __ ] okay I'm gonna derail this
real quick the Kieran jindosh's uh
robots in Dishonored 2 are the [ __ ]
best best barks that exist in video
games right here into nauseous Clockwork
Mansion the AI are walking talking
robots and what they express are literal
statements
about what they're seeing subject has
been detected I can't remember the line
specifically pretty much yeah it's
basically like
um the subject seems to be detecting
something to tell you this this robot is
in the caution State because it it's
detecting you the stealth meter is
filling up but they're all spoken by the
inventor so all the vo is the guy who
invented the robots expressing what the
robots are seeing to you the player
as well as helping the player yeah it's
it's very and it makes perfect sense
because he's like a maniacal inventor
and they're not quite ready and it's
just such a creative and original use of
just a very simple
a way to like hey we just need to tell
the player they're being spotted so they
they hide hey you've been detected know
that it's an alert State now in combat's
beginning but the way they expressed it
oh just delete that game's so good
Nobody Does it Like arcade I love him so
much I really do such a soft spot my God
um Carrie how about you what what's a
thing that you think the industry can
improve at or something you would like
to see more of
um well I mean there's a couple of
things because it's kind of a big
question I definitely think we could
do better especially like I come from
AAA space
so
I'm used to making games with teams of
hundreds and hundreds of people and I
think
nobody really understands what any other
department does with any great degree of
clarity
uh and so you sort of have this this
world of the game that as you understand
it in narrative or in design or in art
or whatever and I think we could be
better at breaking down those walls and
being like here is what narrative brings
to you in this space here is what
writing will bring to you in this space
and then I mean you can say that for art
you can say that for design and I think
the more that we can work
collaboratively in saying like we want
this space to be scary how do we make it
scary what's the gameplay element that
makes it scary what's the narrative
element how do we do the art so that
it's scary how's the lighting
contributing to that and come together
to create a vision in a much more
structured way
I would really like to see more of that
I always said I was going to do a
writing for non-writers seminar and I've
never actually sat down and put my my
thoughts on paper as to like how that's
a good GDC talk yeah how do you explain
to people who do not write for a living
exactly what writing brings and then
it's not just like I type words on the
keyboard and because I can type whole
sentences it's good a lot of it's design
I think in in ways that I didn't expect
when I started is that a lot more of it
is is uh with design in mind I also like
have to write things with a budget in
mind a lot of the time okay writing is
designed 100 yeah for sure like can I I
mean I'm on the design team so we do
classify it that way at Santa Monica
Studio but like can I afford the set
piece I'm writing no we probably can't
afford to do this thing that I wrote
like that because if I do write this
then that Konica and that's the thing
that I never would have expected to have
to think about is like this pitch is too
expensive I we have to like pick and
choose where we're putting money and
that's the thing that I never thought
that I would have to think about there's
certainly a lot of rules that apply and
yeah I don't obviously haven't worked at
any other AAA Studio but I I I can
imagine some very big teams
having a lot of trouble with
cross-disciplinary approaches to things
because it especially remote now too I
feel like that's probably even harder
it's just a lot of people siled
processes too right like an animation
team functions day to day different than
a writing team that's not better or
worse it just is true everyone does what
is best for their teams and and finding
ways to work better together and be
aware of each other's limitations and
strengths and how you can kick some ass
together super important what's an
example of a game that that either of
you would think um especially a
narrative Focus one that has uh nailed
that in terms of like what I would
generally consider that to be as good
direction like a game that clearly has a
cohesive point that they have absolutely
executed on very well do you have
anything every single game with the
Yakuza in the title
you're not wrong
I think the real good to go go to uh
ryukagotoko team is very very very good
at
merging narrative and design in ways
that sometimes don't make sense but
that's sort of the ideal time but also
they they bring it together in ways that
are like
how do you make a video game about uh uh
like two
real estate rival Feud people fighting
over a plot of land how do you make that
a compelling crime drama
you use every system available to you
use everything that has ever appeared in
a Yakuza game in a way that is
fundamentally engineered to enhance that
drama yaku says a a weird one in that
like they somehow managed to also have
like a plot where a woman is so
traumatized from an abusive experience
that she goes blind in the same game as
their uh phone sex mini games and at no
point does it feel inappropriate like
you're always like yeah this makes sense
all of this makes sense in this world
for some reason somehow because the tone
is just so specific and so erratic that
I do feel like that is a really good
example of good direction
um I actually think Final Fantasy VII
remake is a very well-directed game you
understand what that game is heading you
towards and what the point of it is and
that all of the pieces are leading in
that One Direction in a way that I feel
like is pretty hard also death Loop very
well directed I would think okay back on
that Arcane kick it's always okay
I mean you can also say things like
um
uh breath of the wild too which is that
game is telling you a ton of stories but
it's almost all environmental narratives
and it's just
so cool to walk around and stand in the
middle of something and be like what is
the story that this ruined city is
telling me
about what happened here and who these
people were and and that kind of thing
because and at such different scales
right like whose gravestone is this
versus like who Cleaves that mountain in
half yeah yes what the [ __ ] is that
thing
it's a korok seat
oh it's golden poop
um off of that I guess like what uh what
are your favorite games what are games
that you you often you know think about
of things that you would aspire to do or
things that you were inspired by
as writers of course
Carrie I can Vamp for about two hours
about jrpgs if you need time
oh my god well I'm trying to
I'm trying to think because I don't want
to say things that are like way out of
it
um
you could give something out of date
that's still bad I mean I love the Zelda
games breath of the wild being the the
most recent one that I've played
um I think it's the most recent one
that's come out next year we have what's
it called tears of the Kingdom
for the kingdom
sad Kings
cheers
and the big sad Queen tragedy
oh how long may she live
uh I actually uh I was talking with some
friends about the Assassin's Creed games
which
because I left I haven't played the last
couple of ones
uh and so I've kind of been out of it
for a while but we had talking about
like what were your favorite games in
the Assassin's Creed series and I was
like Brotherhood and then I had to get
it for the switch
I love that shame that whole idea of
just having that you know gang of
Assassins that you could send out and
send it on little missions I did that
pigeon coop [ __ ] so much
it was so good
ridiculous and I yeah I love those and I
love the little missions that you could
go on I thought they were super cute
they did cycle after a while but I loved
that they just made it any civilian and
so it could be you could have a
Brotherhood that was actually all women
um
and
it's surprising to me given how hard
I've had to fight to have women in games
sometimes that mother had just did it
and no one questioned it and it was
never a thing
um
so anyway yeah it was it was that was a
good one yeah that definitely my
favorite Assassin's Creed I I absolutely
loved it though I how does it hold up if
you just played it on switch is it is it
still I'm not very far into it okay but
I feel like it's also like Assassin's
Creed's a tough one in times of age
because they've like so clearly improved
upon that formula over time especially
like the climbing and the combat but now
I feel like it could be difficult to go
back but I've not tried I did love that
game uh Mitch how about you what are
some of your favorite games games that
inspire you something you'd be proud to
work on whatever
uh as mentioned huge fan of arcane's
games love Dishonored one and two uh
really love death Loop and prey uh for
the same reasons that I like something
like breath of the wild right uh and any
open world game where there's just a
shitload to do and innumerable ways to
approach it so I play Far Cry games
every time they come out right it's I
understand there's a problem that exists
right here and based on the tools that I
have and the knowledge that I've gained
and the information that I don't yet
have and I'm glad that's in that cage
yeah exactly uh I'm gonna approach this
problem and solve it in whatever way
suits whatever's happening to me in this
world at this point in time
um but I'm also I joked about jrpg stuff
but like I'm I've just fallen down such
a rabbit hole of those games over the
last few years old new
um I like the trails of Cold Steel Games
the kiseki series a lot it's not only
because it's just like an interesting I
really like daily structured uh games
like uh you see some of that in Persona
right every day like you start school in
April and you go through literally every
day every day is a different Quest and
there's different quests on different
days and different opportunities
available to you on different days
there's holidays that only happen once a
year
um things like that
are interesting to me in the same way
that like an immersive Sim is because
it's just a different experience every
time uh
and even though at jrpg like that might
be structured it's every time you replay
it it's like well this the broad Strokes
of the story are the same but the color
and the texture of it based on the
choices I've made are dramatically
different
it makes sense um yeah and then near
automata any excuse to say that Game's
name out loud I think that's one of the
most ambitious and interesting
narratives that exists how do you
convince people to play a game five
times in a row
well you make every single one of those
narratively more substantial than the
last playthrough how do they do it I
don't [ __ ] know I genuinely don't
know how it's possible I don't know how
they pulled off what they did it is
incredibly inspiring and I'll never get
to do anything that cool man so good
I just uh have been playing through
replicant because I only played a little
bit when it first came out and then just
recently been had been playing more of
it because I didn't play the original
neon launch also very good
video games they're very good how do
they do it before I want to ask you a
question because uh congratulations to
everyone on this call our games have
gone gold it's true we're all shipping
video games this fall congratulations to
all of you yeah Alonzo this is your
first AAA video game that you've shipped
how do you feel
uh just excited there's no better
feeling than working on a game that
you're [ __ ] excited to play that you
genuinely love that you can see the
strengths of because when you're working
on games all you see like you see it at
its worst literally from the beginning
yeah so you never get that experience of
seeing it the way players will you never
get to see anything in your game for the
first time the way it was intended to be
seen I'm just really excited to watch
people play it like to to see how they
react to certain
beats or like certain places or certain
you know whatever just things that I had
a hand in or didn't at all have a hand
in which is majority of the game and
just see how people react I just want to
see it I'm just like oh he just put it
out now come on it's already done just
just getting away yeah no it is it's
really really exciting and also just I
think um
you know working on a game is a really
collaborative effort I feel like we've
touched on that multiple times and
for that whole team has been working on
the game for such a long time like the
amount of people just um
can we have like a a a celebration party
and it's just I'm just like this is just
a lot of excitement like to
to have it be out in the world it's just
yeah just a very very positive
experience and let me tell you coming
from media and then I mean I was still
technically in media at Rooster Teeth
where you work on something like Mitch
and I both worked at IGN everybody uh
that you work on for two hours that's
then out and disappears in an hour to
working on something for years that is
out and is [ __ ] thunderous and exists
for years is a really really gratifying
thing like not working on something that
just disappears immediately
um that's just forgotten and instead
being like hundreds of people
collaboratively working together and it
comes out to thunderous Applause in
theory
some people are excited
um
and uh and just like having that as a
shared experience is is much much more
rewarding than working in media I think
it's uh it's a very nice change of pace
so yeah excited it's all very cool and
congratulations thank you you too your
games out before mine is so
congratulations on that I'm very by
several days I think
I think you're weeks aren't you what
what day does it come back give me the
giveaway October 21st pre-order now
there you go what do I get if I
pre-order if you get the deluxe edition
you can get the night watch suits by Jim
Lee X oh that's actually another content
I forgot so those suits are sick for
real so you're a few weeks two weeks
exactly uh before us or no not quite
close to close um okay well thank you
both for joining me where can people
find you make sure you on the internet
somewhere would you like to share
anything I try not to be good choice
unfortunately that's a lie you can find
me on Twitter at Mitchy d uh that's
basically it that's my internet presence
now I was gonna try to screw you to play
Gotham knights with me on stream so
well you might have to do that when it
comes out you can find me on
twitch.television
uh how about you Carrie I
I also the majority of my presence is on
Twitter uh at Carrie young writes uh
Carrie is spelled ceri I guess you can
just see it on the screen there uh and I
also have an Instagram account under the
same name but I don't close there very
much so if you want to occasionally see
me like at a Gotham Knight's mural and
be like it's my game I do want to draw
this but it's pretty look at this what
uh well thank you both so much for
joining me thanks for having us
the chatting and I'll see you all next
time bye